ازمه اسقاط منطاد التجسس الصيني تفاقم
التوتر بين واشنطن وبكين حيث اتهم مسؤول
في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البانتاجون
اتهم الصين بانها تمتلك اسطولا من مناطيض
المراقبه للتجسس في سماء خمس قارات وقال
المسؤول الامريكي لوكاله رويترز ان
المنطاد الصيني الذي اسقطه الجيش الامريكي
هو واحد من ذلك الاسطول واضاف ان المنطاد
لم يكن مرتبطا بالارصاد الجويه بل ارادت
الصين استخدامه للتجسس على مواقع عسكريه
حساسه ونقل مسؤولون امريكيون مشاهدينا عن
الجيش انه سيحاول سريعا انتشار المكونات
الرئيسيه لمنضاد المراقبه الصيني من بين
الحطام قباله سواحل ساوث كارولينا بعد ان
اسقطته طائره مقاتله من طراز اف 22 في
المقابل الصين ادانت بشده الهجوم العسكري
الامريكيه على منطاضها الذي تشتبه بانه
لاغراض التجسس الخارجيه ذكرت انها طلبت
وبوضوح من الولايات المتحده معالجه الامر
بشكل مناسب وبهدوء ومهنيه وضبط للنفس
متهمه الاداره الامريكيه بالمبالغه في رد
الفعل وانتهاك الممارسات الدوليه بشكل
خطير واضافت الخارجيه الصينيه في بيان
بكين ستحتفظ بالحق في اتخاذ المزيد من
الردود الضروريه وكانت طائره مقاتله
مشاهدينا طائره مقاتله عسكريه امريكيه
اسقطت ما يشتبه بانه منطاد تجسس صيني
اثناء تحليقه قباله ساحل ولايه يوم السبت
بعد اسبوع من دخوله لاول مره المجال الجوي
الامريكي الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اوضح
انه اصدر امرا يوم الاربعاء الماضي باسقاط
المنطاد لكنه وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اوسط
بالتريث حتى يمكن القيام بذلك في منطقه
مفتوحه فوق المياه لحمايه المدنيين من
سقوط اي بقايا من المنطاد على الارض